VERY MUCH SO.
34 PAST THE HOUR.
BACK TO D.C. LAWMAKERS GRILLING
BIG TECH CEO ON HUMAN
TRAFFICKERS USING THEIR
PLATFORMS AND WHAT THEY’RE
DOING OR NOT DOING TO STOP IT.
FACEBOOK AND TWITTER AND GOOGLE
EXECUTIVES.
WOULD YOU SAY IT WAS A GRILLING?
>> IT DEFINITELY WAS A GRILLING.
THEY WERE CAUGHT OFFGUARD BY
THE ANGER THAT WAS SHOWN -- THE
LEVEL OF ANGER FROM LAWMAKERS.
CROSSING THE BORDER IN THIS NOW
APPARENTLY ILLEGALLY STARTS
ONLINE IN MANY CASES.
SOME OF THE LAWMAKERS ARE
SAYING THE SAME SOCIAL MEDIA
COMPANIES THAT BANNED FORMER
PRESIDENT DONALD TRUMP HAVE
BECOME ADVERTISING CONDUITS
OFFERING HELP AND GIVE CARTELS
ACCESS TO MORE PEOPLE TO HUMAN
TRAFFIC.
LISTEN TO THIS EXCHANGE AS
HOUSE LAWMAKERS CONFRONTED THE
FACEBOOK CEO MARK ZUCKERBERG.
>> MR. ZUCKERBERG DO YOU FEEL
COMPLICIT IN ANY WAY THAT YOUR
PLATFORM IS ASSISTING IN THIS
DISASTER?
>> CONGRESSMAN, WE HAVE
POLICIES AND WE’RE WORKING TO
FIGHT THIS CONTENT.
WE HAVE POLICIES AGAINST SCAMS
AND PAGES GROUPS AND EVENTS
LIKE THE CONTENT YOU ARE
TALKING ABOUT.
WE’RE ALSO SEEING THE STATE
DEPARTMENT USE OUR PLATFORM TO
SHARE FACTUAL INFORMATION WITH
PEOPLE.
>> REPRESENTATIVE BUDDY CARTER
SAYS HIS OFFICE FOUND FACEBOOK
PAGES AND INSTAGRAM POSTS
OFFERING TO TAKE PEOPLE ACROSS
THE BORDER ILLEGALLY FOR A FEE.
PRESIDENT BIDEN SEEMED TO GIVE
THE GREEN LIGHT FOR PARENTS TO
SEND UNACCOMPANIED CHILDREN TO
THE U.S. BORDER SAYING HE IS
NOT GOING TO TURN THEM AWAY.
THIS IS THE KIND OF INFORMATION
FLOWING FROM THE CARTELS
THROUGH SOCIAL MEDIA TO PEOPLE
IN SOUTH AMERICA AND THE
NUMBERS REFLECT IT.
LAST MONTH 171% MORE MINORS
SHOWED UP WITHOUT PARENTS AT
OUR SOUTHWESTERN BORDER THAN IN
FEBRUARY OF 2020.
IT IS SIMILAR INCREASES FOR ALL
PEOPLE SHOWING UP AT THE
SOUTHWESTERN BORDER.
THE INTERNET IS FOREVER, THE
WORD GOT OUT U.S. BORDER IS